STEP FORWARD THIS YEAR. FOR KONO
CATCH UP, HE DOES.
DART BEHIND THEOST ARDENT FLYERS
FIVE EIGHT, 160 POUNDS.
SHOT TO THE SIDE OF THE
NOT A GREAT PACE AND KALE CLAGUE
LOOKING TO MAKE A PLAY TO THE
MIDDLE OF THE
GOOD RELAY, HERE'S PETRY!!
DISLODGED.
SUZUKI NOW WILL CLIP THAT FOR TE
FLYERS TOO.
PLAY IT BEHIND THE GOAL.
HOGBERG UP ON THE LEFT JUST ENDP
SCORING 20, 25, 30 A YEAR.
>> Dan: AND HE'S GOT IT OFFN.
IF YOU'RE THE RIGHT WINGER,
YOU'RE TYLER THROUGH
MISSED THE NET.
HUNG UP BY THE S COME
IN HERE AND THROUGH HIS FEET.
ANDERSON OUT THERE AS WELL.
THE PUCK GOES AIRBORNE, A CHANCE
FIRST.E FLYERS TO G G
DVORAK CLEAN WIN, CLAGUE TO WORK
THE POINT.
GALLAGHER BEHIND THE NET.
TEN SECONDS LEFT IN THE ATTACK.
HARVEY-PINARD THROUGH TO SCORE!
TIPPED IN FRONT BY
HARVEY-PINARD, HIS OWN GUY.
HE JUMPS INSIDE TO
MACEWEN KNOCKED AWAY BRIEFLY,
FOLLOWING UP, THEY SCORE!
THE QUICK SHOT BY SIMILAR SPOT O
PROVOROV'S GOAL EXCEPT THIS HAD
THE MOVE.
IT WAS A BROKEN PLAY AND I DON'T
THINK CAREY P
SETS IT UP, A GOOD PASS AND A
SHOT AND KONECNY SCO CANADIENS.
GOOD PASS HE'S ON
THE MOVE. ANDERSON BUT NOW
CAUFIELD GETS A FORTUNATE CATESO
E
ON THEFOR THE FLYERS AND MAYBE .
CAUFIELD SHOOTS AND SCORES!
[ Cheering ]
[LICK.
DOWN THE WALL, TAKES THIS